the perimeter of a rectangular fence
measures
0.72 kilometers
the length of the fenced area is 160
meters what is its width now the first
thing that jumps out at me it might have
jumped out at you is that they're giving
us different units they're giving us the
perimeter in terms of kilometers and
they're giving us the length in terms of
meters and i'm assuming that they want
the width maybe in terms of meters since
that's what they're giving us the length
in so what i want to do right from the
get-go is just convert the perimeters
into meters so we have the perimeter and
i'll just represent that with a p
is equal to 0.72
kilometers which i'll write km for short
kilometers 1000 meters that's what
killed the prefix kilo means and so we
can say that for every one kilometer we
have a thousand meters or we have one
thousand meters
per
every one kilometer
and you might say sal how do you know to
multiply by a thousand instead of divide
by a thousand and one way to think about
it this is probably the best way to
think about is this look a kilometer is
a huge is a bunch of meters it's
actually one thousand meters so if i'm
converting kilometers into meters i
should have a much larger number
whatever my number is in kilometers it
must be a much larger number of meters
so that's what tells you to multiply and
also if you if you care about
dimensional analysis the dimensions
cancel out here too we have kilometers
in the numerator kilometers in the
denominator and so when you multiply it
you have 0.72 times a thousand meters
and to multiply anything times a
thousand or really any
power of 10 you say look if i multiply
it by 10 i'll move the decimal to the
right one space
that would be multiplying it by 10 it
would be 7.2 multiplying it by 100 would
give us 72 if we're multiplying by a
thousand that would give us 720. and
i'll put a trailing zero here just so
that we have something to move to the
right of so this is going to be equal to
720 meters so that is the perimeter now
let's remind ourselves what the
perimeter even is and then hopefully we
can figure out the width so let me draw
a little box over here
so let me draw a little box
and they tell us that the length is 160
meters so let's say that that's this
dimension right over here the length is
160 meters so that would be this
dimension and this it's a rectangle so
these sides are both the same length
and our width is what we need to solve
for so that's our width and this is also
our width
and the perimeter is the measure going
around it so the perimeter is going to
be this length plus this width plus that
same length again plus that width over
there
or another way to think about it and
this might be a simpler way so there's a
couple of ways you could think about you
could say that the perimeter
the perimeter is equal to
the length plus the width
plus the length
plus the width
and then we know what the length is so
the perimeter would be equal to
160 meters
plus the width
and actually let me write the units down
160 meters plus the width plus 160
meters
plus the width
and then we then we know what the
perimeter is that's actually 720 meters
so
720 meters
is the perimeter so you'd get 720 meters
is equal to 160 meters plus the width
plus 160 meters plus the width now
there's a bunch of different ways to
solve for the width one way you could
just say look if i just have the width
plus the length once that's going to add
up to half of the perimeter so if i just
go halfway around if i just go halfway
around the rectangle that's going to add
up to half the perimeter so if i take my
width which is w plus my length which is
plus 160 meters this should be equal to
one half of the perimeter this should be
equal to one-half times our perimeter
which is 720 meters or you get width
plus 160 meters is equal to one-half
times 720 or 720 divided by two is
360 meters
and so now you have a situation where we
have the width plus 160 meters is
360 meters so we could now subtract 360
from both sides so or sorry we could
subtract 160 from both sides to solve
for it or you could even do it for your
head if i say something plus 160 is 360
you could in your head say well that
something must be 200 200 plus 160 is
360. so you could just say your width is
is 200 meters or if you want to do a
little bit more formally you could say
look subtract 160 meters from both sides
from both sides of this equation and you
are left with the width is equal to
the width is equal to
200 meters so that's one way to do it
we've solved the problem the other way
is you could actually go straight from
this equation so we get 720 i'm just
going to assume everything is in meters
720 160 meters plus 160 meters is
300 is 320 meters and that's going to be
the same thing as
the width plus the width or 2 times the
width anything plus itself is just 2
times that anything
now if if 2 if this plus 320 is equal to
720 you could do it in your head you
could say well look what plus 320 is 720
well this thing must be equal to 400 or
you could do it more formally and
subtract 320 from both sides of this and
you would get if you subtract 320 from
here you would get 400
is equal to subtract 320 from this side
you get 2 times the width
so if i have 2 times something is equal
to 400 that something must be 200 or if
you want to do it more formally you can
divide both sides of this equation by 2.
either way you will get the width is
equal to 200 meters